it's a year now since Hillary Clinton
lost the US presidential election to
Donald Trump and the Democratic Party
has gone on losing in state elections
around the country my guests here in
Washington is Neera tanden a longtime
adviser to Hillary Clinton why are the
Democrats finding it so hard to put the
past behind them and find a new
direction
[Music]
Neera tanden welcomes conflict sir
thanks for having me this summer Donald
Trump managed to get his ratings down to
the lowest for any president at this
point in his 10 years since records
began how is it that the Democrats have
failed to get any political advantage
from this well I would say that they
were able to so far successfully defeat
the Trump's various versions of the
health care bill they have they don't
control Congress or the executive branch
so really their their ability is to
influence even just a handful of
Republicans which was which was what how
they were successful in the health care
bill but the same poll that had Trump
such low ratings also put the Democratic
Party as standing for nothing except
being against Trump forty forty eight
percent have a negative view of the
party in fact you're flatlining in the
polls you have done for the last 12
months yes the parties both parties are
unpopular the question really is how but
people make a choice in the elections
and we'll see in November they're two
governor's races and in in the United
States how those candidates fare and the
special elections Democrats haven't won
those special elections but Democrats
have been outperforming how they've been
do how they did last November so we
haven't had a lot of tests of that I
would say that Donald Trump has a strong
opposition in the country we are now at
close to 50% strongly disapprove in
variety of polls and whether people that
makes people actually vote for Democrats
is a big open question I believe the
Democratic Party has to fight Donald
Trump but also has to provide an
alternative to him as well but he's had
a horrible six months he's is under his
campaign has been under six separate
investigations the white house is
totally dysfunctional he's made a lot of
promises he couldn't keep it you should
have picked up a lot more if you can't
kick a a politician when he's down in
this city where can you then races that
have existed so far there have been five
special
actions he lost the illest Oliver there
are five special elections Republican
performance in those districts is by 20
percent up 20 percent over Democrats in
each of those special elections we're
talking about Kansas Montana Georgia
Georgia South Carolina
exactly there's Democrats came close
within three four or five points and
they made up a gap so in it we have it
we've yet to have an example and we will
now we have Virginia in November in
Virginia you have a race that's a purple
state it's a pretty close state we'll
see how Democrats perform I think the
question then the big question in
politics today is that there is a big
resistance to trump there's a big
resistance to you as well well I'm I am
just I'm within an organization but I
would say I'm not I'm not the leader of
the Democratic Party but I would say
that I think you'll see we see signs
that Democrats are planning to vote at
higher numbers and Republicans they have
in the special elections and I think
you'll see not reflected in the
fundraising is it and the parties no
that's not true the parties broke that's
not true three point five million
dollars in the red yeah it's it's the
candidates the big question is whether
candidates are raising money and the
candidates Democratic candidates are out
raising Democratic candidates for house
or out raising House Republican
candidates even though they're in the
majority in the first six months of the
year the Republicans raised almost
double the amount that the Democrats got
did in the DNC but not as candidates and
this is small donations from people
donating under $200 so it's grassroots
support this is what they wanted to be
up there picking up grass roots no
you're there's higher grassroots support
amongst Democratic candidates House
Senate governor's races then on the
Republican side I think you're looking
at the Democratic National Committee
versus their art where the Republican
National Committee the Republican
National Committee does control the
various parts of the government so that
it's easier to fundraise that way but I
think if you actually look candidates to
candidates Democrats are actually out
raising Republicans the House Democrats
just from out
the Republican the House Republicans
month after month after month there
seems to be no agreement on how to deal
with Trump
apart from resistance the party seems
unaccountably clueless about how to
fight how to take the fight to trump why
do you say that well because I'm looking
at some of the things that some of the
congressmen are saying that Jim Himes
for instance of Connecticut he said the
Democrats must do more to compete with
expansive and unrealistic promises made
by the president Debbie Dingell from
Michigan we need to show working men and
women we understand their anxieties and
fears isn't it isn't it shocking to you
that people actually having to say that
this is like the first day at school
here we have to understand anxieties and
fears this is so basic to politics isn't
I do think Democrats have an opportunity
and progressive candidates have an
opportunity which is that on every issue
the president has put forward he has
created almost every single issue he's
created a broad opposition in the
country Paris the Paris deal was a 50/50
issue 55/45 issue a year ago now it's
two to one in support of Paris if you
look at the affordable care act portable
Care Act before he started talking about
it I was at 38% approval now it's at
close to 60% but there are people in the
Democratic Party and Tim Ryan of Ohio is
one of them have you have you met a
party so far where everybody agrees on
everything but I haven't met a party
before where people are saying our own
brand is toxic which is what Tim Ryan is
saying there's just no doubt about it
we're not connecting with people the way
we need to connect with them our brand
is worse than Trump yes I think he did
say that last January and I think the
question right now for the country is
its people agree with the opposition to
Trump and Democrats have to offer an
agenda for upward mobility how people
who have been struggling not for 8 years
or 15 years but for decades how their
lives are going to improve we've put
forward ideas
Senate leaders if the forward ideas of
that how to create more - yes since the
election was lost why is it taking so
long because the thing that Congress
does is deliberate on health care on tax
policy what about the party is the party
spending all this time tearing itself
apart no the party is coming up with
ideas and Democratic Party in the United
States is a party of its candidates
candidates we have more people running
for office as Democrats in the house and
in the house than we have ever had and
still you have the director of the
Elections Research Center Wisconsin
Madison University Barry Burton he says
it's a bit surprising that Democrats
haven't managed a single victory yet and
haven't had more success in turning
their anger against the Trump
administration into something tangible I
wonder I don't I have to say I find that
interesting because again it's not just
interesting no it's not true I mean if
you look at a straight the five races
we've had Republican numbers in those
races right so people who vote as
Republicans is on average twenty percent
higher if the people had an expectation
that even with Donald Trump you can make
up 20 points in South Carolina that
seems to be unrealistic it doesn't mean
it's gonna transfer nationally no it
means that you have to look at a race
like Virginia which is a close race and
see how that know that and if you don't
win that yes that would be a bad sign
but Ralph Northam is just how to pull
out and when she's 13 points ahead of
his opponent now I'd rule it be 13
points on Election Day will it be 10
will it be 12 will it be 8 I don't know
that trust is a problem isn't it trust
in the democratic it's not it's there's
a trust of all institutions Democrat
representative in Congress Pramila
jayapal says I don't still don't think
voters trust Democrats I think they
don't necessarily know what Democrats
stand for and how they differentiate
from Republicans again this is basic
politics 101 isn't it I mean I've lived
in politics I'm never been I can tell
you what I think what I think the
Democratic Party stands for it I think
the Democratic Party stands for or
progressive politics for at large stands
for people who need
like a champion people the underdogs and
people who do need help not the people
who are well-connected and doing really
well in this economy so what so what's
the pitch I mean Donald Trump has had
his pitch make America great again
what's what's the pitch for the
Democratic Party
we're the party that's about upward
mobility for people who haven't had it
stock is doing fantastic sup but
mobility isn't working why is upward
mobility upward mobility has nothing to
do with the stock market how where do
you see people people's portfolios are
going up the challenge of the system is
that only 50% of Americans don't really
have a portfolio so the stock market has
nothing to do with them that I think is
the challenge in our economy which is if
you haven't gone to college if you live
in a rural community if you live in an
excerpt you're standing still or falling
behind I think Donald Trump expertly
tapped into that anger the opportunity
is that he has done nothing to help
those people in fact he's made it worse
his health care bill hurts working-class
but his base is solid his base remains
solid solid he was at a 30% strong
support the week before election day was
at 45% with the week before Christmas he
was at 45 percent 45 percent of the
country now he's at 35 percent 60
percent the worst numbers anyway for
anyone but I completely take the point
there are people who have questions
about Donald Trump and they they have
the question for them is are they going
to come out and vote against him or his
party in the upcoming elections I see
plenty of evidence when used to have
Democrats outperforming Republicans by
14 points in races where Republicans
have a twenty point advantage that seems
to me that's a story of lots of
Democratic enthusiasm not so much
Republican enthusiasm but we'll see in
these coming races whether that's true
so why don't people in the polls think
that the Democrats are doing a better
job I think according to CBS poll only
in the summer only thirty percent of
voters approve of the job Democrats are
doing in Congress did you look at the
Republican numbers
for the last eight years but you're not
proud of these numbers why why they
should be better at the end of the day
if you're a party that's opposing action
like health care people see you as
opposing Mitch McConnell's numbers have
been terrible for years but he he had a
strategy which was to stop the Terry
what he thought were bad things Obama's
doing and make Obama not effective and
he was rewarded in the polls even though
Republicans in Congress have had
terrible numbers for the last eight
years I do not think Democrats in
Congress are the question you should be
asking I think the question you should
be asking is how our Democrats have when
people ask are they gonna vote for
Democrats or Republicans in the House
races
what are they saying and they're saying
by eight points they're going to vote
for Democrats it's the largest margin
it's been in years and since in fact the
last time Democrats took the house back
which was 2006 your ideas conference in
May this year Bernie Sanders wasn't
invited we didn't have anyone who's run
for office he's the most popular
politician in the United States
according to actually he's not them as I
think Bernie Sanders has done amazing
work but there are lots of demo there
are lots of candidates who are more
popular than we're adding that
candidates officeholders her former
office holders Barack Obama Joe Biden we
didn't have any of them because they had
learned for office before you're still
angry with Sanders
there's attacks on Hillary Clinton
during the campaign I'm not angry i i i
have applauded senator sanders work over
the last year as a vehement champion of
the affordable care act he has done
rallies around the country those have
been those have been exceptionally
helpful i think he's done critical
critical work this is since the campaign
since the election but what about during
you said he drove a lot of Hillary
Clinton's negatives I mean we had a row
we had she drove a lot of her we had a
very hard fat primary I think Ted Cruz
drove negatives for Donald Trump because
he was running against him Bernie
Sanders drove negatives really because
he was running against her I I think
that's that is a fact I'm not saying
it's like her numbers were only because
of Bernie Sanders or anything like that
let's look at Israel because he tried to
change the platform for the Democratic
Party on Israel didn't he but he he was
highly critical of what he called
Israeli brutality but the platform ended
up with not a mention of the occupation
that hit 50 years this year and actually
did in the end have language about the
historic treatment of Palestinians and
some reference to the settlements if I
recall there was some language in the
final sorry I didn't see it but one of
the people who helped draft the position
on Israel and the Democratic Party was
Cornel West professor Cornel West and he
said we're at a turning point now for
too long the Democratic Party's being
beholden to the pro-israel lobby AIPAC
such a beholden to AIPAC and didn't take
seriously humanitary of the ban I mean I
think Cornel West I sat side by side
with Cornel West and he had lots of
criticisms of the Democratic Party I
still think I think at the end of the
day he is not a Democrat the party
afraid of the pro-israel lobby I think
the party at Barack Obama just
championed the rand nuclear deal of the
Center for American Progress and
Democrats voted for it so I think that's
the position of the Democratic Party how
long is the blame game for the election
loss going to go on the Democratic I
would hope it would end soon it's been a
year is that time the party got over I
think that I actually think the vast
majority of the people in the Democratic
Party Bernie Sanders supporters Hillary
Clinton's official reporters are
actually over it if you look at the
primaries that have happened over the
last several years several months
democratic party primaries lots of
people who voted for Bernie Sanders are
voting for moderate candidates John
aasif one amongst Millennials they came
out and large large but he was one of
those in Georgia he lost he lost but he
was a moderate candidate who a lot of
Sanders supporters voted for they I
think Donald Trump has
I've been more unifying amongst
Democrats and you see Bernie Sanders
supporters Hillary Clinton supporters
all voting for Democrats and a lot of
moderates winning and a lot of
progressives win he's a big push in the
party to change the leadership at
national level isn't that is there
because congresswoman Cathleen rise she
said the entire Democratic leadership
team should go then the Sanchez just
reported in the paper now senior House
Democrat explicit in wanting the House
Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi to stepped
yes I was going to pass that or actually
at the same time I mean this is up to
the members of Congress the Democratic
House members and the Democratic Senate
members to decide who their leaders are
but Nancy Pelosi did would stand a
challenge and she wants to look Jordan I
that's up to the House Democrats I think
Nancy Pelosi has done a great job
unifying the caucus she's a much better
negotiator than Paul Ryan she will end
up at the end of this year probably with
perhaps more democratic accomplishments
and a negotiation right there a divide
that is is difficult to heal I mean
they've been talking about this in
California if we don't heal the divide
in the party between the people who
being blocked from rising up the
hierarchy because of these people like
Nancy Pelosi in the seventies they are
blocking the rise of a new generation
that they there were so many great
leaders in the house Democratic caucus
right now if you look at what's
happening online and social media on TV
and blogs Seth Moulton Jason Kander
didn't win but Joe Kennedy jr. Kathleen
Clark these are phenomenal leaders in
the party who have a very strong voice
you know again I have to say I think
people who are fixated on having
internal battles as you just mentioned a
minute ago isn't it time to move past
the internal battles to me I think the
answer is let's focus on what we can
accomplish with what we can't what we
can defend against what Donald Trump
into these internal battles comes
Hillary Clinton's book I think if you
read the whole book
she takes on plenty of blame herself I
understand that but how helpful is all
this to the party I know the book is
gonna make her a lot of money but does
it help the party move on you know I
actually think that I think there's a
lot of trepidation about the book ahead
of time because it was sowing division
etc but I actually think for a lot of
Hillary supporters the message of the
book the overall message of the book is
this was this was a defeat for Hillary
but there was a movement that was
created and that that movement needs to
engage in politics now that we cannot
like go to bed or go away but if you
care about if you cared about voting for
Hillary you have to care about resisting
Trump and I think actually the book has
done has been incredibly helpful in that
way even her attack on the party in June
before the book came out saying I
inherited nothing from the Democratic
Party I mean it was bankrupt its data
was mediocre to poor non-existent wrong
I had to inject money into it she's
still bitter she's still pointing the
finger at others there was one quote out
of like a million different issues yes
she said well you always have to pick a
quote but I mean is there any way in
which that quote looks nicer than it is
it just stirs up bad blood in the party
doesn't it I think Hillary is trying to
be I think Barack Obama I think Hillary
Clinton are all trying to be as helpful
to the Democratic Party I'm sure she's
going to raise money for the party she's
going to campaign for candidates that's
the test of these things soon as al
franken had to tell enough say enough
basically it's time to time to move on
we have to move on by proving we're the
party that cares about a lot of the
people who voted for Donald Trump yes I
agree I agree with that and I think she
does too actually if you read the book I
think she does say that her economic
message didn't get through enough and I
think that's an important important
argument I think the Democratic Party
right now is in a battle for the hearts
and minds of people and the competition
is you know an ugly xenophobic
racialized politics whether it's
Charlottesville or the Muslim ban or
Trump statements in Puerto Rico he's
trying to appeal to people by attacking
you know basically
Mining their hatred of other people and
that's what the Democratic Party is up
against today and we have to have a we
have to do a better job I think Trump a
lot of people voted for Trump thinking
he would be a champion for after working
class
his policies have betrayed that and was
up to Democrats to not only criticize
Trump and the fact that his health care
bill hurts the people who voted for him
but in his tax plan hurts the people who
voted for him and helps the super
wealthy but you have to have an
affirmative Hillary Clinton said on a
recording just just posted on your
website I believe in reason and facts
but she also has yet to admit not that
her use of a private email server was
wrong she did eventually manage to say
sorry but the fact that she failed to
tell the whole truth about it to the
American public how did she not tell the
whole truth about well you take the
fact-checking website PolitiFact it
reported in August last year mrs.
Clinton repeatedly said she didn't have
any classified information in her email
marked or unmarked after the FBI
investigation including the interview
with Clinton FBI director Comey said she
unequivocally did they rated her
statement as they put it cover so
colorfully pants on fire okay I really
appreciate is still on the record
actually referencing one PolitiFact
statement and Hillary Clinton when there
were maybe I don't know seven million on
Donald Trump
I mean Clinton is never gonna be on the
ballot again she's never gonna be on the
ballot again she's not gonna run for
president again she's not gonna be she's
not running for Senate she's not running
for governor I think it's fair for her
to try to provide a history of what
happened I think the idea that she was
not candid and at the time when she
released all of her emails or all these
emails there was the other point she
didn't she said in repeatedly in 2014
that she turned over all work-related
emails to the State Department the FBI
said she hadn't done that
the FBI recovered several thousand
modulated emails the FBI had
new investigations going on during the
presidential election they had one of
Donald Trump and they had one of Hillary
Clinton and the FBI director only
publicly commented on one of them he
there was a Republican there was a FBI
investigation of Donald Trump and his
connections to the Russians and his
campaigns considerably my point is that
she wasn't wholly honest I think it's
really all due respect the idea that
you're spending time focused on Hillary
Clinton's veracity when we have a
president who lies all the time
strikes me as not useful she's now
running for anything
she lost the race these facts have been
established how can you ever claim the
moral high ground if you don't tell the
truth any I mean I'd say like I to be
candid with you I think I feel like
there are people who've done misdemeanor
crimes who have more honesty than Donald
Trump Hillary don't you care about the
piece was exonerated by the FBI who
still has has a current investigation of
his not handling of classified
information so she more or less Donald
Trump okay but that's not the way they
make a night why are you asking about
Larry Clinton at all because by April
last year she'd given enough speeches to
be fat check along with her opponents
and truth-telling she was always as you
said way ahead of Trump even slightly
ahead of Bernie Sanders but according to
PolitiFact only 50% of the statements
they checked were found to be true or
mostly true all of her comments of the
ones that they fact checked were also
checked I think that 50% were found to
be true almost true I believe is false
she had many fact checks and maybe
you're checking a weird website but they
solidify price an email or every topic
because I checked her
you checked a lot of her political fact
she often was she got full veracity and
so she was raised as an honest
politician but for only half the time by
PolitiFact you just said more than
Bernie Sanders yeah okay case closed
I did I did so isn't it time given all
of this to stop the crocodile tears
about this I mean you've been very loyal
to her for many many years haven't you
had enough of going over the eleven why
I mean I have to say I don't actually
understand why we're even talking about
this which is just to produce the book
that's created some more bad blood in
the I don't know has it created some
pamphlet she had some criticisms of
Sanders he had some criticism of the
back the book is doing really well
millions of people seem to be interested
she has crowds for it who knows I mean I
don't know whether it's actually helped
a party or hurt the party I think you're
making a value statement when you say
it's hurt the party all right it's good
to have you on the program
[Music]